MALE SPEAKER: Scientist,
a best selling author
whose future-oriented
novels include
"The Postman," and "Earth."
His "Uplift" Hugo Award
winners include "Star Tide
Rising" and "The Uplift
War." "The Postman"
inspired a major film; I
guess it wasn't that close
the book so it's
only inspiration.
He's also known as a
leading commentator
on modern technology trends
and his nonfiction book
"The Transparent Society"
won the Freedom of Speech
Award of the American
Library Association.
His newest novel,
"Existence," explores
the ultimate question--
billions of planets
may be right for intelligent
life, so where is everybody?
OK, so I'll hand
it over to David.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID BRIN: Nice to be back.
It's nice to see
some familiar faces.
Thank you very much Mike.
It's great to see your director
of research sitting here,
the great Peter Norwig.
Let's just start
with something that
will give me time
to get my jacket on.
This is a little
something that shows you
how marketing is now
being done for books.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID BRIN: The art of the--
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, thanks.
The great Patrick
Farley is a treasure
that our civilization
doesn't make
enough use of because he
never finishes a damn thing.
This was the first piece of
video that he ever finished.
Some of you might be familiar
with Electric Sheep Comics,
and you should look him
up because he finally
has finished a
couple more things.
The variety of his
talent is amazing.
Those are all hand painted
images from the novel.
I got him cheap
because civilization
hasn't been employing
him well enough.
So you could snatch him up.
In any event, it's
nice to be here
at one of the centers
of human civilization.
Came up here all the way from
the lower left-hand corner,
San Diego.
But we're all sort of
on the lower left corner
of the continent, which is why
everything loose kind of rolls
down this way.
And we're proud
of it, aren't we?
In any event, down
there in San Diego
we just started the
Arthur C. Clarke Center
for Human Imagination.
An amazing center of
trans-cultural, trans-academic
study of this fundamentally
human notion that
is seeded here the prefrontal
lobes just above our eyes.
The seat of what Einstein
called the Gedankenexperiment,
or thought experiment.
Which is that which--
there are three seats here.
There's a more here if
you'd like to come on up.
Don't feel you're
disturbing anything.
These prefrontal lobes are the
seat the thought experiment,
which is what we do
when we think what will
my boss think if I present this
idea, what will others think
if I wear this,
what might happen
if I try to run
this yellow light.
It's where we, largely, give the
answer to this question, nah,
I better not do that.
How many of you guys have had
to say, nah, I better not do
that within the
last five minutes?
Then the rest of
you aren't honest.
The notion that
imagination is part
of this process of creativity
and that it's important for us
to start understanding what
it is, how to enhance it,
but also how to help train
our children and our neighbors
to be able to tell the
difference between what
they imagine and what's real.
Because what is the
fundamental human quandary?
It's the seat of much of our
glory, much of our greatness,
and also much of our tragedy,
ever since recorded time began.
That is our propensity
for delusion;
our ability to
deceive ourselves.
As Richard Feynman put it,
the easiest person to fool
is yourself.
And science is one of
the four great arenas
that we found in our
recent enlightenment that
empower us to find our mistakes
before they become lethal.
If you look across the last
6,000 years of history,
it's been one relentless
litany of horrible errors
of statecraft and
delusions of grandeur,
or delusions of
impotence, delusions
that have left a trail of lost
potential across thousands
of years, and almost
all continents.
What are the four
arenas, that we have
that Adam Smith
recommended, that
take advantage of the
greatest creative force
in the universe,
which is competition.
It made us in nature.
But can we harness
this force without
the incredible
inefficiency and pain
that features
natural competition,
the incredible lost
opportunities, and the violence
and death.
Where the losers have to lose
big time, in order for winners
to incrementally
improve and get better.
You may think you have an angle
on what my politics are just
because I talk about Adam Smith.
You'd be wrong.
The point is that we have
developed four great arenas
based upon the competitive
provision of the only thing
that cuts through our human
propensity for delusion,
and that is
reciprocal criticism.
You cannot see all
of your mistakes.
If you're
scientifically trained,
you're among the few people
in the history of our species
who are at least trained to
find some of your own mistakes,
to have a habit of
saying the words,
I might be wrong let's find
out; which are the great words
of human maturity that took us
thousands of years to develop.
But do you honestly believe that
you catch all your mistakes?
Who catches them for you?
This is why we get married.
I know who catches most of
my mistakes, either before
or after I make them.
But who really
catches your mistakes?
Collaborators?
Good.
That's good.
Your grad students?
How about your enemy's?
This is the ultimate irony.
The people who will supply for
you the criticism that you need
in order to become even better;
the people who supply you
with the grist you need
in order to improve;
the ones who can be
relied upon to provide you
with this absolute necessary
ingredient for your success
are your enemies.
But criticism is the only
known antidote to error.
[INAUDIBLE]
And yet we hate it
instinctively, reflexively.
We avoid it whenever possible.
And this reflex explains
most of human history.
If you're at the top of
a pyramidal social order
and you have the thugs,
and you have the swords,
then the natural
tendency for a human male
is to repress criticism.
Napoleon!
Your emperorness, that sounds
like a great plan except I
hear they have snow in Russia.
It's a gift economy.
Your worst enemies will supply
the criticism that you need.
And here's the point,
they'll doing it for free.
And you'll happily
reciprocate the gift.
There's always a positive
spin on everything,
and I just put a
positive spin on the
give and take of the hate fast.
But it doesn't have
to be a hate fest.
Think how you are empowered
if the next time your enemies
are criticizing
you, you say, "Yes,
tell me more about that one.
Uh huh, very interesting.
The first four points you made
are utter bullshit, idiotic.
But five and six,
I think you've just
helped me to be even
better, and I'll
be better able to
defeat you now.
Thanks!"
Can you think of
a better win-win
than the look on your enemy's
face when you say that?
When you've actually
paid attention
to the component--
it may be just 5%,
of what that idiot was saying--
that was good, that was valid,
that was useful?
And you had the
strength of character
to say, "Huh,
idiot, idiot, idiot.
Thanks!"
Can you see how strong
it makes you look
and can you see yourself
actually doing it?
It's kind of iffy.
When I teach writing
I emphasize workshop,
workshop, workshop so that
you can get the criticism,
and get the pain that
leads to success.
But to find pain attractive.
Well we're a generation
that at least
is familiar with the
notion of going to the gym.
I've been a little less
familiar with the notion lately.
I still got some guns though.
My son's are 17 and 21 and
the one thing they don't dare
do is meet me in a-- I'm 63--
meet me in arm wrestling.
So they look at me and
they say, "so, catch me!"
In any event, I am a
member of an industry that
utilizes this spectacular
propensity for delusion
because it is also
the source of art.
It's the source of some
of our greatest things
and that's why we
developed the Arthur Clark
Center for Human
Imagination down at UCSD.
Think about what I do.
Does somebody have a book here?
Let me hold that up.
You probably never
heard of this book,
except I did this great
big sales pitch at you
and called it art.
What do I do?
Magic, if you look
across history,
magic is the use of
incantations, and familiarity,
and images, to create belief
in subjective realities
in other people's heads.
What do I do?
I create incantations of
strings of black squiggles
on pressed vegetable
matter, or now as lumens
rising up from a screen.
And you are so well
trained, and so brilliant,
that you can scan these
chains of black squiggles
so fast that you forget there
are black squiggles there.
You decrypt the
incantation into star
spanning explosions; and
deep human insights; kissy,
kissy, kissy, love, love, love.
And you do it with your
own creative imagery.
None of you see the same thing
when this incantation decrypts.
But with good quality
control-- and at the end
of every one of my books
there's 50 names of people
I circulate my manuscripts to.
I'm supposedly a modern
master of science fiction,
and yet I circulate
my manuscripts
to 50 people in advance in
order to get industrial quality
control.
Because I'm always
trying something new.
I'm trying something daring.
There's so many
ideas packed in here
that I wouldn't be
able to juggle it all
if I didn't get
feedback from people.
I take care of most
of the criticisms
first, before the industrial
product comes out.
But it's industrial grade
magic; creating incantations
that reliably can cause
subjective realities
in your hands to unfold.
Well when you look
at it that way,
I am one of the guild
of a few thousand master
magicians who've ever
been on this planet.
Now that is a strange thing
for Cal Tech boy to claim.
But I was always considered a
bit of a razzle dazzle, song
and dance man, even there;
Gilbert and Sullivan.
The point is, that we
deal in the world in which
the subjective and the
objective are always in flux.
All the great minds of the
past-- well not all of them,
but a great many who come
down to from the past, Buddah,
Jesus, Socrates, Laozi,
you look at all of them
and they all said,
Plato especially--
they all said the same
thing as a premise.
The premise is objective reality
is really hard to grapple with,
and even harder to improve.
In Plato's "Allegory
of the cave;" give up,
you can't see what's
actually real.
You don't know what this is,
you just have an impression.
And therefore, they all said
give up on the temporal world
and seek a more
transcendent truth.
And then they split up
via abstraction, or logic,
or prayer, or the
abnegation of the self.
The specifics vary,
but the prelude--
this is a filthy world that
you cannot get leverage on.
Galileo answered,
"you are right.
My vision is feeble,
my touch is unreliable,
my descriptions are even worse.
I cannot know
precisely what this is.
But with the help
of tools of science,
and the tools of the
mind, and above all
the reciprocal
feedback that I get
in inter-playing with
colleagues and competitors,
we can gradually carve away all
of the things that this is not,
and that is enough to
incrementally, and gradually
make things better."
Now has that driven off all
the transcendentalists who say,
"we don't like to
hand we've been dealt.
We need something else something
elsewhere, something better."
Of course not.
This is ingrained in all of us.
And I'm not just talking
about the religious people
in our culture.
And by the way, I'm not,
strictly speaking, an atheist.
But we all know some of the guys
who are the new kind of people
who are saying, here's a
new way to a better reality.
We're talking about
the post humanists;
the singularitarians.
Raise your hand if you don't
know what the singularity is.
Raise your hand if you do.
Liars.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't have a
clue, and neither
do I. All I know is
that I'm a contrarian.
I'm ornery.
Whenever I am around
people who do not
believe that we can
transcend and get better,
I sound a lot like
a singularitaran.
But whenever I'm around
the singularitarians,
I'm the grouchy guy.
I'm the one who points
out to Ray Kurzweil
that there may be
intracellular computation.
And if there's computation
taking place inside the neurons
and even within the glial
cells that support the neurons,
and between the glial
cells and the neurons--
there is preliminary
evidence for all of this--
then the number of Moore's
law doublings between us
and the 60 trillion
synapses in the human brain
is a lot more, if
for every synapse
there are hundreds or
1,000 calculations that
take place inside the cell.
The good news is that makes
us even more spectacular.
Now we're talking quadrillons,
quadrillions of floating point
operations inside this little
three-pound piece of muck.
Yes I said that-- don't--
it was a metaphor.
But the bad news being,
poor Ray Kurzweil,
the number of
Moore's law doublings
that it would take to
simply emulate quadrillions
it may take us to
the 2080s, 2090s
if that's your faith in AI.
It turns out there are 6 or 7
different general categories
of approaches to AI.
In my novel "Existence"
I talk about one
that I think is a very,
very little understood,
but I think you here at
Google come closest to it.
We all know some of them,
the approach taken by IBM,
the approach of modeling
human brain and software,
the approach that gets most
of the science fiction movies,
is emergent properties.
It emerges out of an
increasingly complicated set
of hardware called Skynet.
[IMITATING TERMINATOR]
I'll be back.
Or the Matrix, or
that sort of thing.
Personally I am very
afraid of that kind.
It's the kind that
sneaks up on you.
And we should be
afraid of it, but I
don't think it'll come
from the military.
Who can tell me
where more money is
being poured into AI than
the top 10 universities
and Google combined?
It's being done in secret, and
the AI that they are forming
is absolutely based upon
fundamental precepts
of predatory behavior,
parasitism, secrecy,
and voracious insatiability.
AUDIENCE: Advertisements
and Wall Street.
AUDIENCE: Hedge funds.
DAVID BRIN: Wall Street
we're dialing in.
Most of it's being
done by Goldman Sachs
and its partners-- what specific
kind of program at Wall Street?
AUDIENCE: High speed training?
DAVID BRIN: What?
AUDIENCE: High speed training.
DAVID BRIN: High speed trading,
high frequency trading.
Vast majority of the trades
taking place in our equities
markets are quick, predatory,
I sense this trend,
I sense this trend, and
they're spending more
on the development of
artificial intelligence
than anywhere else without
any public supervision,
any supervision whatsoever,
entirely in secret.
Does that like a plot of
a Michael Creighton story?
And by the way, all
Michael Creighton stories
are based upon one premise,
and that is secrecy.
This is of course what my book
"The Transparent Society" is
about, which is the notion
that the new era that we're
going into is fraught with
the potential for disaster
and the only way
we will cross it,
is if we can see
where we're going.
But there are so
many temptations.
By the way Michael Creighton
is a character in this book.
Not quite the same name,
he died toward the end
of my finishing
writing it; I was not
going to change the character.
But there's a character who's
based upon him in the book,
and he-- would it give
away too much if I told you
he's the guy who gets the girl?
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
How can we get across
this critical juncture?
Within 10 years, blatantly
and obviously, we
will lie detectors;
functional lie detectors.
There will be fMRI based
methods for tracking
certain kinds of thoughts
and at least attempts
to engage in deception.
In my novel, "Sun
Diver" in 1980,
I had using eye tracking
as a lie detector
and as a method for detecting
deception and other personality
traits.
It seems more and more
likely to come true.
Under those circumstances,
if we tumble
into any form of Big
Brother, it will be forever.
But under those circumstances,
if we can avoid Big Brother
and apply those tools to
all of our politicians,
and our oligarchs,
and our aristocrats,
we will never get Big Brother.
And this critical crossing
of the next decade or two
is what I try to
write about in "Earth"
and in my near term,
grownup, science fiction
like "Existence."
You always have to watch
out for temporal chauvinism.
Temporal chauvinism is
saying, "This right now.
This time.
This is it.
This is the most
important time."
And if you had asked
me, my 30-year-old self,
I would have said 1980.
But the fact is that the
trends are like this.
These four great
accountability arenas that
enable us to apply
reciprocal criticism
to each other, and competition,
and thus find decent products.
What are they?
Well I used the word products,
so therefore the first one
that comes to mind is markets.
And Adam Smith
recommended that we
keep a flat, open,
equal opportunity market
system, so that competition
results in good goods
and services.
Those of you on the
left of the spectrum,
you have been doing yourself
and Adam Smith a great disfavor
by not really reading him
and realizing how heavily he
emphasized the
flat and open part.
And how in 1776, he demanded
free public education
for all children.
Those of you on
the right, you have
done him and
yourself a disservice
by assuming that
he said, "oh, it
doesn't matter how
much money anybody has.
Let anybody become a Lord
and then meddle in markets."
Well he never said such a thing.
He and the American founders
rebelled against that.
And we're facing this issue,
this problem of the recurring
zero-sum game of success
that destroyed past markets
in the past-- past
Renaissances of freedom.
In 99% of human cultures, those
who won for whatever reason,
whether they won by delivering
goods and services or using
swords, what would they do?
They would immediately kill
their immediate competitors
and make sure
everyone else was too
afraid to try to
compete with them.
Because they wanted their sons
to own other people's sons.
And that's your pyramidal
social structure
that dominated 99% of
human civilizations.
What is the shape of
our social structure,
and I'm not saying perfectly.
What is the shape of our
ideal social structure?
A diamond.
A flattened diamond, with
is empowered, confident
middle class.
And some people get
rich, ideally fairly.
But they cannot send out thugs
to prevent competition the next
time.
And that's the notion Adam
Smith was talking about,
that constant churn.
That in this diamond, even if
you were born at the bottom
you don't necessarily inherit
the position of your parents.
And if anything
is systematically
causing you to inherit the
position of your parent,
then something's wrong with the
system and it needs tweaking.
And the well-off
outnumber the poor.
Is this ideal?
Do we live up to it ideally?
Of course not.
But the ideal is in
our hearts and when
we consider there to
be unfairness going on,
this is what we aim for.
I had a paper, an essay, that
was syndicated by Bloomberg
about four weeks
ago, that pointed out
a little bit of
mystic numerology.
The last three
centuries all appear
to have started
on their 14 year.
It's very interesting.
1714, the War of
Spanish Succession
ended and started what was
called the French century,
which ended in 1814
with the fall Napoleon.
Which led to the great
century of colonization
and industrial growth and
the vigorous optimism that
crossed the 19th century,
from 1814 until--
AUDIENCE: 1914.
DAVID BRIN: 1914.
What happened in 1914?
The curse of Queen
Victoria; three
microsyphallic lunatic
grandsons of hers
ended what was pretty much
the greatest peak of hope
the world has ever seen.
In the preceding
decade people had
been getting into their
increasingly middle class
homes; automobiles,
refrigerators, radios,
telephones, electric lights,
gas ranges, plumbing.
And then they would
all leave their home
as quickly as possible
when they heard one sound.
What was the sound?
A flying man.
Knowing, while staring
up there, within 10 years
we're going to be doing that.
Everything was looking
like it was on its way;
filled with optimism.
Then we entered what I call the
concave century, because wanga!
Even though progress
continued-- progress continued!
But boy was our mood foul.
And deservedly so, down to
the pit, the nadir of 1943.
And since then climbing out,
climbing out, climbing out,
climbing out.
And you see this curve?
What does it remind you of?
Starts with a S, everybody sing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID BRIN: Kind of looks
like that, doesn't it.
But what about our mood?
Foul, foul mood.
Maybe not you guys in this
room, you work for Google.
But just the horrible
mood people are in.
Maybe it's just wishful
thinking on my part.
It's 2014, it's time
for a change of mood.
Do you know what it's time for?
What it's time for?
Its time for [SINGING] The
dawning of the age of-- Oh,
you're all too young.
Somebody ask some
of the old farts
here what I was trying to say.
No.
All right, some old farts
have gotten good rejuvenation.
Whatever you're
taking, I'll take some.
We don't know what it's
going to be this year
and probably it's
just numerology.
But it would be kind of cool
if we snapped out of it.
Maybe somebody will slip the
right drug to Rupert Murdoch.
That could do it.
The other arenas-- markets,
democracy, science,
and justice courts.
It's masked from us how similar
they are in basic process,
because they have very
different products and therefore
very different
superficial rhythms.
Markets, we can afford
a huge error rate.
Personally, I'll take
Beta-Max even now.
Huge error rate,
but huge fecundity;
huge productivity of new ideas.
Democracy can afford less of
an error rate than markets,
but it still has
a very large one.
It's filthy, and noisy.
Science, has a fairly low error
rate, but science is special.
Science has a god.
Science has a god, it's
called objective reality.
You can go to the
scientific conference
and everyone can
say, you're wrong.
And you just say,
wait, objective reality
will prove me right.
What an irony that science
has this solace of faith
that if know you're right,
someday you'll be proved right,
so you can be relaxed.
Justice courts can afford
almost no error rate,
and still they have it.
But that's why they're prim,
meticulous, totally uncreative.
But they all have
the same rhythm.
There is a centrifugal
period when
you can organize and
coordinate your forces
and your product in safety, in
your company, attorney client
privilege, your tenured
lab, your political party.
But then there is an
irresistible unrefusable call
to ritual combat in the
marketplace, in the courtroom,
at the scientific
conference, in the election.
And this rhythm
keep things going.
But what is the fundamental
ingredient they all need?
Light.
They all work best when
most of the people involved
know most of what's going
on most of the time.
And to whatever degree shadows
exist in these four arenas,
to that degree, they fail.
Now I fly east to
Washington, DC every spring.
It seems there are people back
east in these agencies who
are smart enough to know they
need to consult science fiction
authors.
So I fly east to DC,
so does Werner Vingy,
so do the other hard
science fiction guys.
And they say, "show us
some scenarios about how
enemies could
really screw us up.
Scare us."
And they always go, "yeah,
like you can scare me."
And they always leave
the meeting going, "agh."
One fellow at one of
these meetings, he said,
"I know how to destroy
the United States.
Come up with a drug that turns
all of our science fiction
authors into enemies
of the United States."
One of the nicest compliments
I've ever received.
Actually if you want to
compliment an author,
the best thing you can say
to the author is, "damn you,
damn you.
I almost lost my
job because of you."
Because the fundamental thing,
what are we trying to do?
It's a sadomasochistic
relationship.
We want to make it
almost impossible
for you to feed the cat, do
your report, do your homework,
or feed your children.
If we have made this
trouble for you,
and made you almost
miss a deadline,
or almost miss your
job, or whatever,
here's the thing--
you'll buy our next book.
We've settled what you
are in this relationship.
So I should rip out this
outer and underneath
I have leather on.
I don't think that's an image
you really want your head.
No, no, no, no, no, in fact I've
never thought of that before.
I would have to get
it here at Google.
I've just come here from a
four-day meeting at Stanford,
of the NASA Innovative
and Advanced Concepts
Group, where I'm on
the board of advisors.
Some of the wonderful,
wonderful concepts
that we saw at this event
show that ingenuity is not
forsaken, especially not the
United States of America.
It's in trouble.
It's always in trouble.
The war on "science," quote
unquote, isn't helping at all.
The inability of
our political cast
to work out their
differences and restore
a process of negotiated
consensus, which
has been killed primarily by
a set of foreign oligarchs.
This is a bad thing.
And yet there was
amazing news last year
that the press didn't
know what to do with.
I'm going to tell you two
amazing pieces of news
from 2013.
One, the courts
ruled decisively,
and the Obama administration
Justice Department
declared decisively,
that is settled law
that any citizen may record
their interactions with police.
It is probably the most
important civil rights decision
that's been made in 30 years.
It is of spectacular importance
because at the street
is where we get used to our
notions of what is allowed.
And there is nothing
more important
to an average helpless
citizen in their interactions
with authority than
access to the truth.
The immediate result
was an awful lot
of cell phones and cameras
being broken my mistake,
and by accident.
But how quickly things happen.
I predicted all of this in
"The Transparent Society."
How quickly the next card falls.
Before 2013 was out, we
had the image of a big man
in an orange prison
jumpsuit and shackles
being sentenced to
three years in prison
for breaking the camera of
someone he was arresting
and lying about it, because
someone else across the street
caught him doing it.
And you have to
bear this in mind.
You have to say, what
happens if this continues.
It's called Brin's
corollary to Moore's Law,
and people are
crediting Sergey for it.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID BRIN: My son has
the same name as his son.
My son had it first!
Hear that Sergey?
But the point is that
my son will never
have trouble making
dinner reservations.
OK.
All right, it works out.
The corollary is
this, the cameras
get smaller, cheaper,
faster, more numerous,
and better every year at a
rate faster than Moore's law.
I portray this in my novel.
How are you going
to banish them?
How are you going to
do the thing that's
the initial reflex
of almost all people
when faced with
internet age problems?
When you're looking
at next year,
you're not looking
at 10 years from now.
When the cameras are
so cheap children
will peel them off a roll of
stickers with battery good
for a year, or even a
little solar charger
to stick them on a lamp post
and they have their own address
on IPv6 and they
are there forever.
As Clint Eastwood said at the
end of the wisest film ever,
or at least wisest
moment in a film ever,
"Magnum Force," he
squints and he says,
"A man's got to know
his limitations."
Recognize your limitations
and this reflex
to say to authority,
stop looking at me!
Do you honestly think that
you can find any point
in the history of our species
when the elites allowed
themselves to be blinded?
Here is an assignment for you.
Go to the zoo with
a pointed stick,
Climb into the baboon
enclosure, and poke out
the eyes of the biggest baboon.
Tell them I sent you.
Here is a clue--
he won't let you.
And after you're done treating
all your scratches and cuts,
then realize this he will
grudgingly and reluctantly
let you look at him.
What is it that we have
to fear from authority?
That authorities of commerce,
or criminality, or the state,
see or know something about us?
Good luck stopping that.
What's important is
restricting permanently,
and forever, and
ferociously, and militantly
what they can do to us.
And in order to do that, we
have to emphasize not hiding
from authority, but stripping
authority naked and telling
them you are my watch
dog, you are not a wolf.
And in order to do that,
you don't blind the dog.
You need him.
He's sniffing
around for dangers.
But you need him to remember
that the citizens are
in charge.
And to do that
takes supervision.
And that's what we
should be militant about;
and that's what that
news was about this year.
The other piece of news
that came out in 2013,
I'll bet that none of
you even heard of it.
Can anyone tell me
which country on Earth
scored highest in
adult science literacy?
AUDIENCE: Israel?
DAVID BRIN: Israel was
up there in the top 10.
AUDIENCE: Singapore?
DAVID BRIN: Singapore
was nowhere near.
None of you are even
capable of imagining it.
You can't even wrap your
minds around the possibility
that it was the United
States of America.
Not only number one, but double
the adult science literacy
of number two, which was Canada.
Now how can that be?
Our children are all idiots.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] from
all those other countries.
DAVID BRIN: I'll
explain it to you;
and no pundit explained
it therefore it
was just erased off the
radar, it just vanished.
It's actually fairly simple.
The word adult, remember
these prefrontal lobes,
they really only start
kicking in around age 20.
By age 25 most
people have got them,
but I've just
explained teenagers.
Trying to grasp the consequences
of their actions and all that,
it's all abstract to them.
Most scoring systems for the
success of schooling measure
memorized knowledge,
and memorized skills,
and procedures, and these
have to be beaten into kid.
And we don't beat our
kids so we score badly.
But meanwhile they're
learning verbal agility.
What are the kids do
mostly in high school?
Argue!
Argue with the teacher,
argue with each other.
It's class discussion,
class discussion,
who cares what you memorize.
So when they go to college
and they take the same course
again, they say, this
is kind of familiar.
And a new part of
their brain is saying,
maybe I'll pay
attention this time.
What is the difference between
the American baccalaureate
degree and the degrees in
most parts of the world?
Most of the world it's a
three year bachelor's degree
in which the student
specializes at age 17.
Most Americans don't
even know this.
When I asked overseas
when I lived overseas--
and most Americans
haven't lived overseas--
but when I lived in Paris and
I lived in London and I asked,
why is our bachelor's degree
four years and yours is three?
And the answer was
almost universally,
because your students
are so stupid.
When in fact the reason is
because we have a whole year's
worth of breadth requirements.
If you're a science
major, if you're a nerd,
you have to take a fair
amount of history, English,
and all those things.
And what is the result?
Our nerds have experience
with these subjects
and they say, gosh, that
was my easiest course.
I could get an MBA.
And you are sitting in the
valley that that attitude made.
But more than that,
humanities, arts majors,
you have to take three
or four science survey
classes in college, after
your prefrontal lobes
have kicked in.
And that is enough to explain
the wispy, wimpy, ridiculously,
horrific 23% adult
science literacy
that Americans
scored so much better
than the rest of the world.
It's horrible.
And it's better than
the rest of the world
simply because our bachelor's
degree is what we instinctively
know bachelor's
degree ought to be;
that is a time for you to
explore and become, excuse me,
a gentleman who can
then learn anything.
And that's what
you're supposed to be.
Now does it sound
like I'm painting
this rosy picture of everything?
We're going to take authority!
We're going to
look back at power!
Our kids are wonderful!
Human beings suck.
I'm accused of being
this incredible optimist,
when in fact I know what
is likely to happen.
This diamond shaped
social structure
is almost certain
to collapse, as it
did of the few
other times that it
was tried, back into the
old pyramid of power.
And when that happens,
the oligarchs will do--
and I don't care whether
they're oligarchs
of the left or the right,
whether their commies
or bazillionaires-- they
will do what they did
after the Athenian
democracy of Pericles.
They will make it their
number one priority
to make sure it
never happens again.
Only this time they'll be
equipped with the technologies
that you're providing them.
You!
Shills of the oligarchy.
Or you liberators
of all humanity.
And more than just
humanity is at stake here.
I was going to show you
a whole big slide show.
all sorts of things,
and I just shook
hands with Frank Drake
just an hour ago
because he was also
an adviser at this SETI panel.
Who can tell me the most
famous thing about Frank Drake?
AUDIENCE: The Drake Equation.
DAVID BRIN: The Drake Equation.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Predicts
intelligence in the universe.
DAVID BRIN: It's a method
by which we calculate
a general notion of how
many other intelligent life
forms there should
be in the galaxy.
You've all seen it, right?
It takes a number of
stars in the galaxy,
multiplies it by a
fraction, percentage.
Which fraction of them
are stable and solitary;
which fraction of those
planets; the number of planets
that orbit in their
Goldilocks zones.
15 years ago we knew
almost nothing about that.
We knew of no planets
outside the solar system.
Now we know of well
over a thousand.
2,000 more are candidates.
And just down the road
they're building the successor
to Kepler, which should
find us 10,000 more.
So that part of the equation
is starting to fill in,
but the fraction of
those that develop life
is looking more plausible all
the time, but we don't know.
The fraction of
life bearing planets
that develop
intelligence, don't know.
I've spent the last 30 years
cataloging explanations
for what's called the
Fermi paradox, and that
is that this equation seems
like it ought to result
in a galaxy filled with noise,
and sound, and commerce,
and communication.
And the SETI Institute,
just down the road here,
they are very confused.
There doesn't seem to
be anybody out there.
It's quiet out there,
maybe too quiet.
And this is a
point that I raise,
because I've been
in this for 30 years
and I'm one of the
dissenters out there
who are very critical of the
recent trend for impatient
radio telescopers
to say, OK, we're
not hearing anything transmit.
Maybe we should
wait a little bit.
But among these
things is the notion
of is intelligence of
our kind difficult.
And there's recent
reason to believe this.
How many of you've heard of the
recent news about prairie dogs?
That parrots, and crows,
corvids, have vocabularies
and can use tools.
Sea lions, otters.
That so many species are
just behind the chimps
and the dolphins in
the number of words
in their discursive
vocabulary, or their ability
to parse out problems.
Prairie dogs, it
now appears, they
have analyzed the
barks of prairie dogs
and it contains human
passing through the town,
female wearing a red sweater.
Sweater isn't in there,
but the word red is.
Now what does this mean?
First, it's spectacular!
Our natural tendency to enjoy
the notion of the spreading
around of categories, and
appreciating otherness
is improved.
That's great!
But they all crowd
against a glass ceiling
that appears to be all
that Darwin and Mother
Nature will allow.
And there's every
reason to believe
that maybe the
velociraptors bumped
against that same ceiling
that's easy to reach.
And why?
One of the biggest
of all questions, why
did we pound through so
vastly beyond anything
that we might have expected.
Not only just beyond to
become masters of this planet;
because all we needed for that
was 100 word vocabulary, stone
tools, and fire.
"Ogric wave.
Fire.
Chase goat this way.
Me stab."
And we went so far beyond that.
And then we developed
glass lenses,
and we could see more;
and printing presses,
and we could know more.
Vastly more than anybody
would have imagined.
Match And then schools,
and then you guys,
each generation getting a
new fire hose to drink from.
These are the questions
that a lively civilization
needs to be asking.
And with that, I think I'll
give you all opportunities
to buy some books.
And I'll be happy to sign them.
Do I have time
for any questions?
MALE SPEAKER: Maybe 1 or 2.
DAVID BRIN: One or
two, I went over.
Here I thought I
was being so good.
Thank you so very much.
[APPLAUSE]